I wanted to map my experience as an
improviser becoming Trump to the movie
Tootsie and just do a twisty and like
have me teaching him proudly open the
same way as Tutsi like teach you got to
work and you got to do this and then I
can't get a job and then I wear the
orange wig which is just like totes you
she's got red bag and then just do the
beats of it and then reveal myself that
still could happen I think it would be a
great special idea now we've put it out
on a Comedy Central affiliated radio
program
[Music]
I had something happen to me this
weekend that I just want to celebrate
before we get into anything else is that
I left my purse in a cab yesterday it
was devastating yeah it would mean but I
like I always say with because I
practice meditation I didn't freak out I
really think that's the reason that I
don't because generally I would just go
oh my god you're such a idiot
myself and and I'll and my passport was
in there and that's my only form of
identification because I drop my ID on
the street mm-hmm and and I was just I
got to my apartment and I'm getting
ready to go Andrew and I were coming
back from Philadelphia we took the train
train to a cab cab to my apartment got
out and then we're up in my apartment
I'm there for an hour before I realize
my personal how are you paying for stuff
did you just have like a wallet or
something also I like I took my keys out
of my bag while I was on the train cuz I
was like I just want these on my person
I don't know I probably saw it coming
like I feel like I've set myself up to
lose my purse because I was able to get
in my apartment I was able to some part
of your mind
chose and also like some part of your
mind both knew but also was like I'm
leaving this yeah that's the interest
why did I believe in that thing I don't
know because here's the thing so let's
get down yeah and I and honestly once I
realized I lost my person I'm like the
only thing I really need in there
is my passport eventually but not until
I need to travel next which could be for
a couple weeks and then I could just and
I've lost my ID before on a trip and
they it's a little bit of a hassle
uh-huh you can get through security I'm
at the airport but then so I go online
and I file the reports and it's Sunday
so no one you can't get someone over the
phone and I was just like that's fine
were you certain at this point that it
was in a cab yeah because I remember if
you knew you had it gone is it gone or
have
[Music]
[Laughter]
I remembered yeah you know what you just
are trying to remember the last time you
felt it or held it it was like I
definitely didn't leave it on yeah and
and then I was it's definitely in the
cab and then and Andrew was at my
apartment at the site we were about to
go to lunch and that's why I was like
where's my person I got to grab it
because my wallet and I was like oh no
and and he was freaking out a little bit
more than I was I was just like it's
fine like I could pay for things with I
have a bunch of cash just from just a
drawer of kids I shouldn't say that yeah
yeah I had enough cash to get me by and
then I also you can just pay for things
electronically like yeah and your phone
I use my CVS app to pay for things I you
can use Apple pay Starbucks like the
things I buy are all app anyway yeah
post mates yeah I don't know when I even
pay for things with a grinder that's
true seamless is just a thing where i'm
like just food comes when i press this
button that's amazing i use it for the
first time last week i was like i have
you seen this a couple times before
unlike a personal computer yeah you're
getting some food you know the delta is
a proud boy now is that right he's dead
or proud web a.m. extent
but I I called I was really just like oh
well this is life things could be so
much worse than losing your stupid purse
like who cares I was like let's just go
to lunch I filed all the things and
because there's oh and I didn't know
this you go lost item cab you google
that send you to a website you file a
report and then they make you pay $30
that's a scam
place your ad that's a scam I almost did
the same thing for my Nintendo switch
and people were like don't do this it's
like I did it because I'm like and I
could pay electronically I don't to
convenient not to spend the money you're
placing an ad where I don't even
understand exactly I was so angry not
because I had to pay the $30 but people
who lose their like no one is 30
and then they make you pay to get
something back that you it's just
ridiculous yeah
couldn't get someone on the phone and it
was almost nice cuz then I would have
been on hold and I wouldn't have been
able to go to lunch it's kind of nice
when you're like well I've done all that
I can do I am powerless yes exactly and
so then I went to to lunch and I felt
really fine about it and I went back
home hours later and and I'm getting no
emails I called it a bunch of different
places cuz then they give you the the
the company the cab company and I call
them leave much doesn't matter I had
resigned myself to like losing my purse
and and sending my Jen our producer and
my assistant on like a wild goose chase
to obtain me some kind of ID which I
don't even know how it began to do that
and and then I get a call from like a
weird number and I pick it up and I'm
like yes and say hey Nikki this is Ron
from the DC improv which I will be at
next weekend yeah squeeze yes
this guy calls me from the DC improv and
I'm I'm heart I'm crestfallen because he
says DC improv and I'm like oh it's
gonna it's not my purse yes
and he goes Nikki its Ron from the DC
improv where's your purse hun and I'm
like that's a creepy way to just say you
know someone call you know where your
kid is just when people kind of like
shame you about the thing that like so
where's your
first Nikki what are we doing a treasure
hunt yeah just tell me what you know so
I go um I don't know do you know yeah
he's like I dunno someone called me and
I'm like what why would they have called
yeah so some guy finds my purse in the
cab he was the second passenger after I
had gotten out of the cab
yeah get in so someone just sat next to
my person was like I'm not even gonna
tell the cab just gets in and doesn't
take any money or anything like just
leaves it yeah I would at least take
money and leave it I mean you take
something and leave it absolutely yeah
I'd be like I'm probably on some
hidden-camera show about morality or
some that's interesting yeah it'll
be great I'd be like yeah I don't give a
ash well I
and this is the benefit of having a just
terrible purse like just a terrible
loser
it just I use a tote bag that I got from
H&M that they give you to put your
clothes my purse because I just don't
care and I'm sorry I think someone was
just probably like this is a bag of
trash which it looks like that too with
a wallet in it yeah so much trash inside
and and the guy I guess the guy got in
and he rifled through it I had a lot of
different things
oh yeah but you didn't have a phone in
there I think he opened my passport he
opened a cheque I had from the weekend
working in Philly he found out it was he
googled me yeah went to my website saw
that the next place I would be was the
deal yeah or you can just walk into any
comedy club in New York well I don't
have any of my New York days on my
website so I don't but it yes it is easy
we've we've established that it is very
easy to murder me if you wanted to
murder me or any of course comedian
we're just putting our information out
there just you're also appearing in
public constant
at anytime someone could murder you and
there's no like metal detectors walking
into a show like no it could come murder
me and it'll be weird to play this some
day when it happens and be like she
predicted but so tread and then music
starts and then she dies later have fun
with that
my posthumous so the guy the guy get the
guy's number from the DC Improv guy I
call him and he's like he was so funny
he goes yeah I opened your person I
realize this girl's day is gonna be
ruined in six different ways because she
doesn't this back because I had weed in
there I check I had like I drops I had I
had so many things that I looked in the
bag to be like what would you think of
this person that's so funny
it's just such a chronic weed habit she
needs eye drops on the ready and had a
PBA card and got off and got my weed
handed back whoa wait we got to get to
that after the break all I want to say
is thank you to brian cuz he called
brian yeah I get Brian's number and he's
like oh this and he was he said that he
had heard some Tom Segura bit where he
was like it was really weird because I
Tom Segura as this bit about you know he
found someone's wall and he was just
hoping it would be someone like famous
or someone and it was just some normal
dude and didn't matter and and he was
like in it in and then I opened your and
it was like a famous comedian and felt
nice that he thought I was whatever but
he he came to my apartment on his day
off and from the Upper West Side it was
like no I'll come to you and brought it
to me I tried to give him $100 he
wouldn't take it I said and he dropped
the date a girlfriend very quick
can I do anything and he was like my
fiance and I will come to a show
sometime great thank you
great thanks Brian Brian just let me
give you money but he wouldn't accept
the money I got my purse back and I just
it was just so nice it just I needed
that
yesterday so badly I just spent a lot of
time on on Instagram reading that's
where I get my news I know in Twitter
moments and reddit just likes being sad
about the world like we're never gonna
respect animals or the planet and I was
just like everyone's trash and then
Brian brings me my bag of trash bang
really I really screamed on the street I
was like I needed you today Brian like I
was so it just made me feel so good but
I do feel like if you're spending enough
money if you take cabs in this city
you're probably well-off enough to not
steal from the airport though I thought
was like well if you're at the airport
you're not gonna steal something you
already got into the airport but you're
switched you left it and like I said
somebody took it though at the airport
yeah I mean I get that that's free
entertainment on the plane I agree I
don't I don't I think there's a
difference but we do steal my back I
don't but if I find something oh yeah
like there was a sweater at TSA that was
just hanging on like someone had lost
the sweater and left it at TSA and it
was hanging there on the side waiting
for a girl to come back and get it you
can't fart on a sweater that's a good
point
I just knew no one was coming back for
this that this sweater was gonna end up
an awesome that night it's a cute
sweater I'm gonna take it uh-huh so
that's kind of like the switch thing
like how am I gonna get this back to
this guy yeah that's a good point I mean
I did I did the same thing you did where
I looked at all that stuff where you
filed the report and then I that's how I
found out that that was a scam that $30
thing but because I called the airport
there oh yeah if somebody turns it in
will we have it but I couldn't be
bothered if I lost something I would be
like I'm not I do not I cannot find it
was only because I was halfway through
settled
my god Sarah Silverman is waving to us
that just made my morning just tracking
each other throughout oh yeah I know
she's she's not coming here I don't know
how we didn't get her but they have a
busy morning but I can just do her right
now all right hey Nikki yeah so good to
be here you're so funny and I really
look up to you oh it's the other way
around never mind
[Music]
you